نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان عن مسؤول
حكومي عن 22 شخصا قتل واصيب 30 اخرون في
انفجار صهريج غاز وسط نفق شمالي العاصمه
الافغانيه كابول وقال المسؤول ان من بين
الضحايا اطفال ونساء واضاف ان تحقيقا في
ملابسات الحادث قد فتح
الجزيره حميد الله محمد جاء اهلا بك معنا
حميد الله تضعنا في تطورات البشر
ما حسب همم مصادر امنيه وحكوميه ان عدد
الضحايا يرتفعت الى 25 قتيل واكثر من 40
جريحا وعمليه البحث والانقاذ ما زالت
مستمره في النفق حيث يصل طول النفق نحو
ثلاثه كيلومترات وان عدد السيارات التي
دمرت واحترق ثاني في هذا الحادث وصلت ايضا
الى 20 شاحنه وسهريج والنفق ما زال مغلق
وان وزاره الدفاع الافغانيه ارسل التي
الاطباء
والمسعفين الى المكان عبر الطائرات بحيث
يقع النفق في اعلى جبال لولايه بروان وفي
منطقه سالم بالضبط وهناك ايضا اجواء لا
تقص ايضا همم بارد وهناك ما نفق من همم
الطريق ايضا مغلق بحيث ان هناك شاحنات
وسيارات ايضا متوقفه على كلا طرفي ال- همم
النفق وهذا ايضا يعني ادى الى فوضى
استنى سلطات المحليه في ولايه بروان ايضا
كانت تحتاج الى امكانيات حيث لم تتمكن
السيارات الاسعاف وايضا السيارات الاطفاء
لم تصل في وقتها الى مكان الحادث وحتى
الان هناك عمليه الانتشار للجوطات وايضا
سحب السيارات من الداخل ما زالت مستمره
حتى الان